hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
we're very interested in human beings
right not just here on the podcast but
we listeners i presume that you like i
are interested in the behaviors the ways
that we operate and the expectations
that different human beings have of each
other right we are human beings human
beings are intrinsically interesting but
because we are some of them we have a
special interest in them but it's also
raising a problem because when we study
the behaviors of human beings it's hard
to get outside right it's hard to look
at human behavior as a disinterested
observer it's too easy to put ourselves
into the shoes of whatever other human
beings we're studying and furthermore
when we find some human behavior it's a
little bit too easy to say that that
particular behavior is actually
necessary or a law of nature or
something like that studying different
cultures can save us from falling into
this trap because different cultures
have different customs and so forth but
maybe even more effective is to study
non-human primates primates are our
closest animal relatives they include
apes and monkeys and various lemurs and
things like that and they behave in
fascinating ways both individual ways
and social ways ways that are similar
from species to species and very
different from species to species
today's guest franz dewall is one of the
leading primatologists and in general
animal behavior
study or animal psychologist i guess
maybe is fair to say
uh that we have he's done a lot of
breakthrough studies to talk about the
culture the morality the social
structures that primates have and
as you might expect some of them you
look at and you go oh my goodness that's
just like human beings i get it i
recognize that and others you go wow
that's very different maybe we could be
that way maybe we should be that way
both sides give us something to think
about he has a new book out which is
exactly along these lines called simply
different
the subtitle is gender through the eyes
of a primatologist so gender remember
back from previous episodes where we
talked about the difference between sex
and gender you have biological sex male
or female and then you have gender
gender is supposed to be some kind of
social construction right and how in the
world could we talk about gender in the
context of primates if they don't even
have you know language and books and
twitter feeds and tumblr and whatever
well you can because there are social
roles that are played by these different
primates therefore you can ask in a not
quite human context does gender arise
and does it get played out in similar
ways in monkeys and apes and other
primates as it does in human beings or
is it completely different i'm not going
to tell you the answer
listen to the episode you'll find
there's a lot of interesting
intricacies going on here and you know
as i say in the episode it's hard not to
think of the implications for humanity
even though it's also super duper
interesting just to think about the
animal behavior for its own sake you
know animals are their own species every
different species that we'll talk about
in this episode has a right to its own
way of thinking about gender and
sexuality and it adds a little bit of
richness to the human way of thinking
about it to understand that our closest
neighbors are facing similar issues so
let's go
[Music]
bronze to wall welcome to the winescape
podcast i'm happy to be here you're very
famous for studying primates and their
behavior all other kinds of animals as
well so let me just sort of set the
stage a little bit with asking
do you care mostly about the behavior of
privates for their own sake or is it
something we do to try to illuminate the
behavior of human beings
well i think i'm interested in many
animals for their own sake as a
biologist
and the comparison with humans well with
primates of course that comes out almost
automatically because we are
we are primates we humans
um but that's not the first goal for me
the first goal is to understand these
animals
and the second goal is when certainly
when i popularize
to to add in humans i noticed that just
reading some of the examples you're
talking about like the
actually i should ask very quickly how
do you pronounce bonobo is it bunnabo
bonabol
i always say bonobo but
i have a dutch dutch pronunciation i
think that's fine maybe that will win
now so the bonobos you know famously
they're uh they solve everything by
having sex with each other as
maybe you put it at one point so
it's almost impossible not to sort of
visualize what that would be like as
human beings right because they are
pretty close to human beings yeah but i
think people always um
since we have so many hang-ups about sex
uh
we we exaggerate things and so when i
say would always do a lot of things with
sex and they have a very peaceful
society as a result
people think that they engage in sex the
whole day basically but you know
their sexual interactions are brief like
uh 15 seconds is a long time
so they're briefed you better look at
them as sort of handshakes or
patting someone on the shoulder but then
using the genitals
so
i think
people um
people also call them liberated which is
very strange word because
there's nothing they had to be liberated
from but in human eyes they look
liberated is because we we would never
act like this or we have trouble acting
like this well i guess that that's my
question you know to what extent can we
overcome the temptation to compare them
to human beings rather than seeing them
as they are themselves
well i think the comparison is still
interesting
and because clearly we are a very sexy
primate even though we don't always talk
about that but we clearly are and so the
comparison is apt and appropriate and
bonobos use a lot of sex for
social purposes
so
there is this
impression in the public mind that
animal sex is for breeding and human sex
is largely for entertainment
but you know that's uh that's a
simplification and bonobos i think
sweetwater of all the sexual activity
has nothing to do with reproduction
because of the curse between members of
the same sex it occurs in situations
where reproduction is impossible it
occurs with females who are already
pregnant or you know there's all sorts
of
situations where they are not
reproducing and they're still having sex
and that's for social purposes the
females for
example have a collective dominance over
the males
and in order to be collectively dominant
they need very strong ties to each other
so they they foster their bonds with sex
and with grooming and food sharing
and
the sex has a strategic political
purpose in their case and and they very
much engage in that and actually
female brothers probably have more sex
with females than is males
and i guess for human beings it would be
obvious to think that the origins of
patriarchy lie in just the fact that
human males tend to be bigger and
stronger than human females is that not
like that in bonobos
uh bonobos um the males are bigger and
stronger okay
and i as a result if if at the zoo
and this hap for example i was at the
san diego zoo when i studied bonobos
they had one male and one female at some
point
in that case the male is dominant
but then they added a second female all
of a sudden there were two females and
they were dominant together so the
female dominance is a collective
dominance
and it serves a purpose because males
can be harassing females and males
sometimes kill infants in some species
like in the chimpanzee
and so the female dominance over males
has uh has a protective purpose for them
it's it's it's it protects them and
their offspring interesting so that but
it's it's that collective behavior that
the other cooperating in order to
overcome the individual strength
advantage that the males have
yeah and it's it's very prominent that
there's now a study that recently came
out on bonobos
uh where they analyzed this video the
interactions the sexual interactions and
they also measured oxytocin after the
fact from urine collection
and um
they found that females are actually
emotionally more affected by sex with
females than with males and also they
they get probably more satisfaction from
sex with females than with males females
have a large clitoris
you know
all mammals have a clitoris people
sometimes forget that and
uh the mouse has a clitoris the elephant
has a clitoris but the biggest clitoris
we find in the dolphin and the bonobo
uh
bigger than in humans and and that is
because in both species dolphins and
bonobos sex plays a very important
social role so there's a lot of sexual
interaction and i think pleasure is
there to enhance it
you've mentioned a couple things already
that that in encouraged me to sort of
dig into the science the practice of
science part of this i mean you talked
about being at the zoo or whatever when
you're studying the primates bona bones
and and others
are is it mostly at a zoo or at your own
sort of facility or out in the wild or a
mixture
well we study um
robos and chimps under all circumstances
i myself have mostly worked in captivity
such as at zoos or at the primate center
where i work
at the moment we do a lot of studies at
the sanctuary the only bonobo sanctuary
in the world is in kinshasa
where we have a lot of bonobos
that are victims of the bushmeat hunting
and so they arrive as orphans they are
then raised by humans
and
released in a colony and then later
they release them in the wild actually
and they have already twice released
them adopted orphans rescued orphans
into the wild
and so we do studies at these
sanctuaries
uh which are which are half captive
because the enclosures are enormous they
are i think 60 acres or something they
are like big forests in which they live
and then you have people who work in the
field and we combine all that data the
the
the approach in primatology is to use
all the data you can get and so that's
both captive data and data from the
field
and is it mostly just letting the
primates do whatever they want and
watching or do you sort of interfere and
try to set up situations where you can
see what happens well i have always done
both so i'm originally an observer i i
was trained as an ethologist which is a
biologist who observes animal
naturalistic animal behavior
so i i initially i did most of the
things observationally but later i
started to do experiments like
with chimpanzees for example bringing
them together and see are they willing
to share food
with whom are they willing to share food
under what kind of circumstances do they
need to get something back for it or can
they do it just
for free so to speak or do they imitate
each other and and what do they copy
from each other and actually the
imitation is very interesting
uh from the perspective of the gender
studies that i'm involved in at the
moment is that um
i think there is a tendency for males to
imitate males more and for females to
imitate females more and for example
young daughters
they they copy the behavior of their
moms
more faithfully than young sons
and so
there is this picking up of the model of
your your own sex so to speak
and that enhances of course um sex
typical behavior and that means also
that the gender concept
is probably applicable to other primates
because they learn things from each
other
and so instead of saying that
sex differences in the bonobo and the
chimpanzee must be biological i would
argue well there's probably a lot of
culture in there because they have a
very slow development
they are adults when they're 16
so they and they nurse for five years
five four to five years
so they have a very slow development
they learn a ton of things in their
lifetime and there's no reason to say
that what they do is biological more
than what we do i think because people
have that impression that we are
cultural beings and and animals are
instinctive but i would say
we are also somewhat instinctive and
animals are also somewhat cultural
beings so so the distinction is not so
clear
so and when you use the word gender uh
it's in uh we actually talked about this
recently with a philosopher sally
hasslinger about the meaning of the word
gender different than the meaning of the
word sex right and i think it's exactly
lining up with what you're saying the
the sec biology is sex and culture is
gender and you're saying that the
primates have both
yeah i think
humans have both of course of course so
um
that that is the curiosity that people
have about biology is that we see gender
differences in society
and we wonder where they come from
now we
we say of course some people will say
they're all cultural and socialization
some people will say they are nature we
have men and women and they're naturally
different
these are two extreme positions in my in
my view because i'm an interactionalist
i think it's always both it's always a
little bit nature in a bit with nurture
and it's very hard to disentangle them
it's very hard to say
let's say masculine behavior it's very
hard to say which part of that is
human nature or primate nature and which
part is culturally uh imposed
and so people like to make that
distinction but we know that it's almost
impossible to make so for example the
media they will say such things is like
this trait is 90
genetic
and then i always think
how do they know that what is 90
i mean it's always an interaction with
something else
they're probably getting mixed up with
uh heritability or something like that
yeah or yeah they
they learn from statisticians that you
can translate the correlation into
percentage explanation and stuff like
that but
it doesn't work that way i think with
nature and nurture
well what do you mean by culture when
you're talking about bonobos or other
primates i mean how do they hand down
culture is it parents teaching children
or is it more complicated
it's not teaching in the sense of active
socialization
and
it's it's not like
a female bonobo telling
her daughter how to behave she cannot
tell that to her and she can show her
how to behave but she cannot tell her
but also in humans i would say
socialization we always think it's a
sort of one-way street the parents
socializing their children i think these
children socialize themselves the
children look around and look for models
male models female models dependent
actually transgender children they look
for models of
the opposite sex of that they were born
with
uh and and that's an explanation for
much of their masculinization of
feminization in their behavior
so self-socialization is a very
important concept and i think it applies
to other primates because other primates
for example young males they
they pay attention to the adult males
there's a recent study came out on
orangutans in the forest
orangutans are also apes
and what they found is that um
the daughters they eat exactly the same
foods as their moms
you know and in a forest you have
hundreds or thousands of of different
species of things that you can eat or
should not eat or see so the daughters
copy what their moms are doing this the
suns
they have a much different diet and and
that is because they watch males also
the males who come by they watch what
they eat and they they copy their
behavior and so i think um in the
primates we see self-socialization along
gender lines so to speak
and i think in humans that's maybe
maybe more even more important than the
socialization that comes from the
parents because the parents they may
tell
whatever their boys to play with dolls
or something like that uh that's the way
parents nowadays sometimes socialize
their children um but if the boy doesn't
want to play with dolls then that's
probably not going to happen so
so you can try but um i'm not sure how
successful you are at that
is there the occasional young boy or
girl orangutan who follows the diet of
the
is there a girl who follows the diet of
the father and and vice versa or is it
absolutely strict
no that's the interesting part i think
the same gender diversity
that we see in human society
is probably also present in the primates
and we don't have good systematic
studies on that
but i describe in my book for example
donna a female chimpanzee
who from a very young age onwards
acted more like a male
she grew up to be later
a robust individual that looked like a
male and acted like a male and hung out
with the males and if the males would
all get worked up and display and
intimidate everybody she would go along
with them and whereas other females
would never do that but from a very
young age when she was three already she
would
she would play with the alpha male
wrestle with the alpha male and the
alpha male was interested in her
normally
these these
adult males they wrestle with young
males not not with females
but um in this case he donna was an
exception and and so from a very young
age onwards
she was more attracted to males he acted
more like a male she became more male
male-like
i would not call her lesbian because he
was not sexually interested in females
or in males for that matter
um
and so i i describe her as a gender
non-conforming individual basically
yeah although she could be she could be
trans if if she could talk and i could
ask her
what her identity was but i cannot ask
her but
who knows she might say that her
identity is more male than female yeah
well no i mean it makes sense if the
culture is you know following the
cultural transmission of behaviors and
so forth is following behaviors of other
apes that you interact with uh and
most
of them will line along sexual lines but
some don't then yeah that's that's what
we're talking about i think
yeah so we have i think we have
diversity
in the sense that you sometimes have
males
who are big males but they are not
interested in politics and they're not
interested in reaching your top position
and they they don't play that kind of
game and they stay out of it
and you have females who act more
male-like
so
gender we usually divide not in male and
female but in masculine and feminine and
everything in between i think gender is
a much more flexible concept than sex
even though in sex also you have things
in between but
sex is
99 binary and and i would never call
gender binary gender ism
is more a spectrum and i think once we
start looking for that in the other
primates we will find a very similar
spectrum probably
and
i can't help but asking this question in
human societies not only is there's this
spectrum of
gender identities and behaviors but then
there are some members of our society
who don't like it
who try to enforce
a more or less rigid dichotomy are there
the same thing in primate other primate
societies
that's for me that's the fascinating
thing is that that's absent
intolerance of that is absent
so so donna was a very well integrated
individual no trouble at all
and have known others i've also known
individuals who have more homosexual
than heterosexual tendencies
and i've never seen trouble with them in
the sense that
i think primates would probably only
ostracize someone or exclude someone
who disturbs the peace who who makes
trouble for them and i can see how they
would go against that but since these
individuals don't
donna was not a troublemaker so since
these individuals don't
there's no reason for them and they
don't have that tendency the human
tendency to label
and to pigeonhole everyone so we we are
a symbolic species we like to paste the
label on everybody you are homosexual
you are heterosexual you are a man you
are a woman we we have all these pigeon
holes
and if you don't fit there are some
people who just can't stand it
uh and and go against that and and
that's not a problem that the primates
have and and interesting i've also
sometimes compared it with some
racial issues because we have some
species where you have a lot of color
variation so for example you have a
spider monkey is called the variegated
spider monkey which which runs from
almost white very light to almost black
very dark
and
these color variations they occur in
captivity for sure
these animals are thrown together and
i've never seen trouble with that but i
recently talked to a field worker who
works in the field where you also have
this variation and he said he's never
seen much of a difference in treatment
between the one or the other and so and
and i think it's because
uh for the primates that's that's not
necessarily an issue color or
sexual behavior or
as long as it doesn't bother them and it
doesn't why would you even react to it
you know and so and so i think um in
terms of tolerance we could certainly
learn something of the other problems
it does seem pretty common in the animal
kingdom to
have some kind of bias for
members of your species that are like
you right to have an in-group and an out
group is is there something like that
maybe with the color of the fur or or
something analogous or is it just you
know as long as you're in my species
you're my buddy
well all the primates have in-group
out-group distinctions
and some are very hostile to the
out-group like for example chimpanzees
have only different degrees of hostility
between between groups
the bernoullis are interesting in that
regard because bonobos even though
they're very close to chimps in many
ways
they are not territorial
so yes they they have a little bit of
tensions between groups at the border of
their territories
but very soon they mingle
very soon they have sex with each other
very soon they sit together they share
food there's now even observations of
females of one group adopting orphans
from another group
um and so
the bonobos have mingling between groups
peaceful mingling
whereas chimpanzees only have different
degrees of hostility so in group
outgroup distinction is a very common
thing in many animals
it's not based on color though it's not
based on
on external features it's more like you
belong here and you belong there you
know it's a i see it's not based on that
kind of features no well this takes us
back a little bit or is a good reason to
go back to
other research that you've done in the
past because my impression is that there
was a lot of emphasis throughout
research on primates on how they are
aggressive with each other how they you
know have hierarchies in groups and now
groups and then one of your points early
on was yes but they're also quite
compassionate and even moral with each
other uh is that is that too much of an
exaggeration do you think that primates
have morality
well it's a big jump
in the sense that um
i started out my studies on empathy
and and i got interested in the fact
that um
when for example one of one of the
chimps is has been attacked and is
distressed and this screaming
that others will go over and embrace
them and calm them down and kiss them
and then
and show reassurance and in humans this
is called an act of empathy so i got
interested in empathy very early on and
and did many studies of it and now there
are you know empathy is now much more
accepted concept in animals and and even
rodents studies on empathy nowadays so
and and neuroscience studies on on voles
and stuff like that but but empathy is
is now a very well accepted topic
and when i studied empathy
uh i noticed that people always
connected with morality the philosophy
philosophers do so
the dalai lama will tell you that
all you need is actually compassion and
you don't need much more to be a moral
being
uh
i don't think most philosophers would
agree with that but um empathy is a very
central part of moral philosophy and
because
why would you be moral if you're not
interested in others that would be sort
of ridiculous and so you do need to have
an interest in others in their welfare
and their well-being
to be a moral being and so
i got interested in the evolution of
morality
i i never say though that
chimpanzees or bonobos are moral beings
because i think there's more to human
morality
than just empathy
i think it's more than that
because there's also
reasoning about
moral rules there is
consensus building about moral rules
that is the enforcement are the guilt
feelings
um
the justification of moral rules and so
and so there is much more i think to
human morality than just um a feeling of
empathy but still
some of the building blocks of human
morality can be found in other species
it's not like we we designed it from
scratch
and is this sense of empathy
more or less universal among the
primates or is it another thing that
varies a lot from species to species
now empathy is found in almost all the
primates and all i would say all mammals
and there's now even birth studies on
empathy
uh i think empathy is a is a general
mammalian characteristic
that i think probably can came out of
parental care which in mammals is mostly
maternal care
which also explains why
empathy is more developed in the female
than the male in general
is regulated by oxytocin which is by
origin this sort of maternal hormone
and so
i think empathy is found in all the
mammals
but
is is in some species much more
restricted than another so for example
if you are a solitary species like let's
say the tiger or something
um
you only have empathy for
certainly not for your victims
the prey uh and you don't you only have
empathy for maybe a sexual partner
or your offspring there's not much else
to have empathy for whereas if you're a
social species like the chimpanzee or an
elephant or a dolphin who who live in
tight societies
then empathy needs to be extended to
other relationships not just modern
offspring it needs to be present between
males and so on that needs to be present
more widespread
yeah
and
it's just one aspect of what we think of
as morality as you already mentioned
another one being cooperation and you
have these wonderful examples even
predating the work that you did yourself
of chimpanzees working together for
things can you talk just about what
cooperation means in the primate world
well cooperation is everywhere
i know that anthropologists at the
moment they like to emphasize human
cooperation and say we are uniquely
cooperative but
i don't think if you compare us with
ants or termites
be gonna beat them you know so
so i think a cooperation is found
everywhere in the animal kingdom
and uh many animals
could not survive on their own i i just
mentioned the tiger the tiger is maybe
an exception but
um there's lots of animals who who don't
do well on their own for example in
in the primates we know that young males
who let's say young male baboons who
leave the troop
um they have a lot of trouble surviving
they they are much better of living in a
group than uh in the period when they're
adolescent when they're between groups
and so uh
survival depends on
living in a group and living in a group
is because you get benefits from being
with others collaborating with others
getting the assistance of others they
want you for predators
that's the sort of the very basic stuff
warning you for predators and helping
you find food but there's also animals
who are actively cooperative like the
cooperative hunters
like orcas and so on or wolves
so yeah high levels of cooperation can
be found in the animal kingdom but what
i always find interesting about
cooperation
is what i call targeted helping when
it's when it's based on an understanding
of the situation of the other so it's
not just
we go all after the same prey and we
catch it together which is one way of
cooperating but understanding the
situation of somebody else and that's
something you can see in the primates so
for example
there are experiments that have been
done with chimpanzees where
one chimpanzee has to select a tool from
a whole toolbox
that the other one needs so so the the
first sympathy needs to look at the
situation of the other one and then pick
out the right tool that the other one
needs so that's targeted helping
where you have what is based on
understanding the situation of the other
and and it requires taking the
perspective of somebody else
and so in in animals like chimps and
elephants and dolphins i think we see
that kind of level of cooperation
so that's what i was just going to say
there's some kind of a theory of mind
these animals not only do they know what
they know but they have opinions about
what other friends of theirs you know
yeah yeah yeah that's related to that
yeah
and and how do you
i mean you mentioned a little bit but
how do you test this i mean how do you
how do you is it again just watching
what happens or can you sort of put them
in a controlled environment and try to
sort of nudge them toward or against
cooperating with each other
well you can see what they do
spontaneously and and and our
observations uh there's many anecdotal
observations of this kind of helping
behavior
but in in the field of course it's a bit
hard to set up these experiments in
addition many field workers don't like
to do experiments because
then they are messing with the lives of
these animals which which is not that
cool you know
so it's a bit tough to do that but in
captivity you you have sometimes like
the experiment i mentioned with the
tools
there was recently a study on bonobos
where they found that
and and this was actually between the
dobbers who didn't even know each other
strangers where one bonobo could release
a piece of food above the cage of
another one
and then the other one would have the
food
uh and they were willing to do that even
though they got nothing in return for it
so
so they're willing to do these things so
there's altruistic behavior and and
targeted helping right there
i guess i should ask what is the typical
diet of uh bonobo or other primates are
they mostly herbivores are the omnivores
um
both of them chimps and bonobos
they live mostly on fruits okay
and leaves
but they love meat
so chimpanzees hunt
male chimpanzees hunt monkeys in which
is very complex task and there's a lot
of debate on how complex it is what they
do is is it highly coordinated
they certainly catch more monkeys when
they work together than when they work
alone
and so um
bonobos are
less cooperative hunters i say but they
if they have a chance to eat meat they
will eat meat and if they can catch a
daika for example or something they will
do so
and this kind of hunting cooperation is
that again you alluded to it already but
just to prod more deeply is it a rising
spontaneously or do they talk to each
other in some way how explicit is the
planning i i envisioned like a bunch of
chimpanzees huddling up together and
saying you know you go over there and
you go over there but that's probably
not realistic no there is sometimes a
task division so in west africa
crystal bush has done many studies of
the hunting behavior in in west africa
and um he says that there's a role
division that there are blockers so
there are males which are usually older
males more experienced males
who go into the distance when they have
spotted a monkey group they go into the
distance and they sit high up in the
trees and wait for the other chimps the
other males
to start hunting the monkeys so they
drive the monkeys through the canopy of
the forest
and then these monkeys meet the blockers
who then capture them and then
afterwards they share they share the
beat with everyone
and so that's a very important part is
that if these blockers would run away
with their prey then of course
it would not be a sustainable
cooperation so it's very important for
cooperation
to have sharing going on at the end
and that's sometimes forgotten because
we did studies on the sense of fairness
i don't know if you know these studies
but we have done studies on the sense of
fairness in monkeys and in apes
and um
people say why would they have a sense
of fairness what what is the function
well the function is that if you have a
cooperative society you need to share at
the end if you don't
that whole cooperation is going to fall
apart
and that's an important lesson i would
say for human society as well
if you don't have equity in human
society if if there's some some guys who
take everything like we now have some
billionaires who take all the money
uh that's gonna undermine the
cooperativeness of the society that's
gonna under it's gonna create tensions
tensions like the french revolution you
know it's going to create tensions that
could be bad
and it's going to undermine cooperation
and so equity
is an important issue in relation to
cooperation it doesn't need to be
perfect that's for sure uh but there
needs to needs to be some degree of it
tell us more for those who have not
heard of it about these uh fairness uh
experiments is this the grapes and the
cucumbers we're thinking about yeah
yeah we started out together with sarah
brosnan i did a study on capuchin
monkeys that was the first study is
because we
we found when testing these monkeys
that they paid attention to what other
ones were getting
and we saw this was sort of ridiculous
like like one monkey does a task gets
rewards for it
but if the monkey next to it we always
tested them together because capuchin
monkeys don't like to be tested alone so
we always had two monkeys side by side
in the test chamber and we noticed that
if the other one was doing better
they got very upset by that
and we saw this was ridiculous because
none of the books about animal teaching
and training talk about this the
comparison that they may make and we
started testing it out systematically
and we we did this famous experiment
that you can find on the internet if you
type in the words fairness and monkey
you will get the experiment
and what it shows is that
one monkey gets cucumber slices the
other one gets grapes for the same task
now if you give cucumber slices to both
monkeys
they will do it 25 times in a row
there's no problem cucumber is perfectly
fine
but if the other one is getting grapes
then the one who gets cucumber and gets
very upset and doesn't want to do it
anymore throws out the cucumber um
and so better it's almost like an
irrational response but if you look at
it from the perspective of a cooperative
primate they are cooperative primates
too
if you look at from that perspective
it's something you need to watch what
you get you need to if you are doing a
lot better than me
i need to pay attention to that i need
to protest against it it's it's not in
my interest to be in that kind of
situation
i mean presumably from kind of a game
theory perspective
if it's just once
that one gets a cucumber and one gets a
grape and that's the end of the whole
experiment then who cares nothing you
can do about it but the idea is
the monkeys know it's not just once this
is going to happen again and they they
want to imagine a fair future for
themselves
yeah and and of course in the chimpanzee
it goes further chimpanzees are apes are
much closer to us
and in chimpanzees the one who gets the
grapes
may refuse to grape
until the other one also gets a grape
so in chimpanzees
they will equalize the outcome even even
if the outcome was in their own favor
and that is a tendency that is that is
more a sense of fairness i would say
then it's not it's not as egocentric as
what the monkeys do and what young
children do
and in humans
i think in the small scale societies it
works the same way if you if you hear
about hunter-gatherers
there's a very strong sense of fairness
among hunter-gatherers is that the
hunter who brings home the meat so to
speak
he sometimes doesn't even have the right
to divide the meat it's the group who
divides the meat for him so um
i think we have that tendency in
small-scale societies it's unfortunately
it's lost
in our massive
multi-million people societies nowadays
it's it's a bit lost and that's because
we have anonymous relationships and
people can get away with these things
well so my data point is that when i was
a kid and i had a brother there was no
sense of fairness whatsoever my brother
would try to take the biggest piece of
everything so is this something that
gets trained into you over time does
that happen with the monkeys are they
just born with this sense of equality
for everybody
so you resent your brother still
about that i'm just saying that he tried
to get the bigger pieces of cake that's
all i'm saying it's a data point
it's a data point i had five brothers
okay so and i know what it is to to
fight for your share yeah
i mean that's what i'm imagining i can
imagine that there are some monkeys who
want everything to be fair you know they
want everyone to get equally but there
have to be some monkeys who just are
very happy to take all the stuff
yeah of course uh
in the in the capuchin monkey is the one
who gets the the grapes never objects to
it that's fine
it's in the chimpanzees which are more
cooperative and more complex
that
even the dominant understands
that he's undermining his own
relationships if he doesn't share
and and i think um that is an
understanding that your brother didn't
have yet
but um at some point he may have
developed that
when he
for example now if you have a meal with
your brother i'm not sure you still do
but if you do
he maybe he understands if he takes
everything that you will not be very
happy
it is true so he has advanced now
to a different stage so i'm wondering
especially since the the different
species are different how well do we
understand why
the behaviors are like this do we have
explanations in terms of evolution and
and so forth or is there an element of
arbitrariness in sort of what customs
arise among different kinds of uh
primates you mean like the comparison
between bonobos and chimpanzees yeah do
we have a theory of why one is one way
or the capital monkeys are another way
yeah we have a theory about chimps and
bonobos which is that
bonobos live in a forest that maybe has
more food to offer
per surface area for the bonobos because
they also have no gorillas in that
forest chimpanzees have gorillas that
they compete with and the gorillas eat a
lot of
ground vegetation
and they would always live in a place
where there's no gorillas
and may have a better food distribution
for them
which allows them
to travel together
so instead of spreading out
as chimpanzees have to do very often
they can stick together
which allows the females to stick
together and female bonobos are very
protective of each other they're very
have a high level of solidarity and so
the ecological circumstances allow them
to have a society where female support
is very important whereas
chimpanzees are more on their own the
females are more often on their own and
have to fend for themselves so that's
that's an ecological explanation
um
sometimes in captivity you know
where chimpanzee females are together so
i worked for a long time with a colony
of 25 chimps
where the females were
by necessity always together
then these female chimps also started
acting a little bit like bonobos they
they help each other and so the the
balance of power between males and
females in captivity is actually better
between the genders than it is in wild
chimpanzees it's because they they're
they're
living together and the females help
each other against overly aggressive
males
so so i think captivity
is an interesting situation because it
sometimes uh
enhances these female cooperative
tendencies does it go so far into what
we would think of as altruism i mean are
are
uh primates really sacrificing their own
well-beings for the well-being of others
or the tribe yeah they will they will it
do you know the literature has been very
cynical about
altivism of animals so altruism of
humans of course we admire and we say
it's wonderful
and so and so on but about animals it
has always been downplayed
like they cannot really be kind and
altruistic to each other
i think that's total nonsense
in in the wild for example chimpanzees
sometimes help each other against
leopards
so one chimpanzee gets attacked by a
leopard
and has a special way of screaming at
that point
and others then come to to help against
the leopard which is a very dangerous
enterprise and we also know that
chimpanzees sometimes rescue each other
from drowning
so this has been observed in um in
captivity mostly where you have
enclosures with moats around it where
and chimps cannot swim and so when they
end up in the moat which sometimes
happens
then others may rescue them which is
very risky and dangerous thing for them
to do but they still do it and and so
yeah i think there is altruistic
behavior and there is sometimes also
altruistic behavior for which they get
nothing back so i described already how
in bonobos they had done this experiment
where one bonobo could produce food for
another
and they did that even under
circumstances where they get nothing
back and and let me give you another
example in chimpanzees we had one time
an old female
in a colony who could who could not walk
anymore barely walk anymore
and and so each time she went to the
water faucet to drink which was a long
distance for her
uh younger females would would run ahead
of her to the water faucet and suck up a
lot of water
and then run back to her and spit it
into her mouth
so they would be helping her to drink
they would also help her to join her
friends in a climbing frame and push her
up to join her friends to groom with
them
and this old female clearly could not
return any favors he could not do
anything for them at that point
she was close to death uh and so and so
there is altruistic behavior that that
is not between kin and it is not going
to be repaid um
and people underestimate i think those
tendencies which are clearly present in
the primates do you think it comes in at
the level of primates or even before
primates or other species
oh i think that there's examples of
other species as well of helping
behavior sometimes even between species
like like dolphins helping human
swimmers against sharks and things like
that are also reported mostly anecdotal
because we don't do experiments on
dolphins and sharks and human swimmers
of course but still um yeah these things
are reported and and i believe that
that's the case and that's all based on
mammalian empathy i think mammalian
empathy evolved
to serve your your own inner circle and
your family and so on it evolved for
those reasons
but once it exists it can be applied
outside of that little circle and that's
the interesting part is that these
empathy tendencies
in the dolphin clearly did not evolve to
help human swimmers but once
that situation arises it can be used
there
well that's interesting in terms of the
kind of mechanism or explanation i
recently did a podcast about the gene's
eye view of evolution and you know
you'll sacrifice yourself for two
siblings or eight cousins or whatever
and that makes sort of a mathematical
sense but but like you say
once a capacity has developed it might
be applied more broadly even if there's
no direct evolutionary advantage right
yeah of course and that's that's often
forgotten in the in the gene-centric
view so one time i had a debate with
with dawkins richard dawkins
who came to see my chimpanzees and i
explained that situation of the old
female who was being held by younger
females
who and the old female could certainly
not do something back for them
uh and and he came up with a new theory
which was that there must be misfiring
genes
now
i don't know you know uh genes are
little little chunks of dna basically
i'm not sure how they're going to be
misfiring but but you know
if you want to look at the world from
the gene-centric perspective you have to
come up with that kind of stories but i
think it is actually much simpler is
that
certain capacities arise for a certain
purpose but once they are there
they can be used for other purposes so
for example color vision
arose
to pick out ripe fruits that's what we
think is that color vision in the
primates is related to picking out ripe
fruits but once you have it you can use
it to to read your google map or you can
you can pick out the right dress to with
your right shoes and yeah so once it is
there it can be used for totally
different purposes
and i think that's the case in in all of
biology
i mean i almost hesitate to do this
after these heartwarming tales of
altruism but i do want to return to the
bad behaviors that primates sometimes
exhibit i mean once you have cooperation
doesn't that open up the door to
free riding or cheating or you're
letting everyone else do the work do we
see that in these primate uh cultures
yeah
yeah that happens and
i think i think um they have ways of
dealing with it so we did an experiment
for example with chimpanzees
where we created a situation where they
could cooperate but also compete at the
same time we did a cooperation test
where the whole group was present like
20 chimps present
meaning that some individuals could sit
behind the co-operators and try to steal
their food for example
or they could
cooperate with others and
and then steal the food of of their
partner
and so they there was a lot of potential
for competition now what happens
interesting
is that um
in the end the chimps became almost 100
percent cooperative
and only a few percent competitive
and that is because
individuals didn't want to work with
these competitive individuals these
competitive individuals learned that if
they walk up to the apparatus the
corporation apparatus the others
disappear
the others say well i'm not going to
work with that guy because he always
steals everything and so
there was partner choice in in the human
literature if you lose you read about
game theory and so you mentioned that
partner choice is an important issue
and i think in in my chimpanzee
experiment also the chimps started to
pick the partners that they liked and
the partners that they liked were the
ones who were
sharing and cooperative
so so yes you have cheating
but it's it's not encouraged by the
system so to speak
it's undermined by the system of partner
choice
and in some sense you know the examples
you're giving
vividly come back to this idea that if
you behave badly
you will suffer down the road right even
you know the the rest of the society is
not going to help you out and this is
probably going too far but in the modern
world which you you brought up for human
beings our societies are so large that
if you know someone were
talking to on a phone helpline for some
company or something like that or or
someone serving us food behaves badly
that that's very far removed from the
people who are benefiting from our
business there and so
is it is it
imaginable that the motivation to behave
better goes away as our societies become
larger is that even something that we
can uh and more diversified uh is that
even something we could see in the
primate world
yes i think the private world of course
is face-to-face contact and everyone
knows everyone and they know each other
sometimes since they were very little so
they know each other very very well
and that's also why they
really cannot get away with that kind of
behavior because that's always
remembered by the others
uh and and
your your talk about comeuppance
also relates to um bullying
by high-ranking males for example so so
i
i'm very interested in alpha males
and uh people always have the impression
that alpha males must be bullies and
must be terrorizing everyone
um but the ones who do uh actually end
up usually very poorly so um
in that sense it's almost like a
democratic system
is that if you have a
an alpha male who keeps the peace
and is friendly with everyone
uh even though he enforces his position
on occasion but uh he keeps the peace
and and he acts empathic towards and you
have males who are like that who are
responsible leaders so to speak
those males become so popular that if if
there's a young challenger who tries to
take their position the whole group is
going to defend him
because
the whole group says well we want to
keep this guy he's a he's a good alpha
male and then if you have the opposite
if you have a male who's a bully
sometimes you have males who terrorize
everybody and they're nasty with
everyone
those males may end up badly in the wild
we know that they're sometimes killed by
the group
there's at least a dozen cases where
they uh
and in captivity
if they are challenged by a younger male
then the whole group is going to support
that young male so in in the sense of
let's try to get rid of this guy you
know and and uh and sometimes in
captivity you need to remove that alpha
male who has been deposed because his
life is going to be quite miserable in
the group so so i think there is a
certain justice in that regard
and and that they pay attention to
the reputation of an individual
and
the typical individuals that i know
high-ranking males
who lose their position and who have
been popular they just step down a few
rungs they become number three male and
the number four male and they they have
a perfectly fine life after that so they
uh they're not ostracized and
they often become sort of the powers
behind the throne because they
they are the ones who decide which which
next meal is going to be alpha male by
supporting that so it's a very
interesting political process and and
at the moment i'm also interested in
alpha females
partly because of course bonobos have
alpha females but also in chimpanzees
alpha females
even though they rank below the males
they're still very important leaders and
they have a lot of power in the group so
i always make this distinction between
physical dominance and power
for example mama the alpha female
chimpanzee of the large colony that i
worked with
she was alpha female for 40 years
she saw a lot of alpha males come and go
and she had more power than most of the
males even though she ranked below
physically she ranked below the males
she had more influence and power
and decided a lot of things in the group
and i think that's an interesting
distinction to make is between
power and dominance
and if you look at it from that
perspective
when people say the natural order is
males dominate females
i would say well
that's questionable because first of all
we have two close relatives where one
one is the females dominant the other
one the male's dominant and secondly
you need to set power apart from
physical dominance and in terms of power
there is a lot of power in the females
how do you measure or quantify this idea
that the alpha female has more influence
over things i mean you can't hear them
talking but presumably there's some
communication going on
so for example mama the chimpanzee
female
she would always be recruited by males
who were in power struggles so if you
have one male challenging another male
it was almost impossible
for the challenger
to be successful
if he didn't have support from mama
because mama
had all the females behind her and she
would
pay attention to what the females were
doing so if if a female supported the
wrong male in her view she would go
against that she would beat up that
female so she would explain so to speak
this is my meal and you better support
him and so all the females in the colony
supported the same male and there was
the male picked by mama
so you can imagine that a male
chimpanzee
would pay very close attention to mama
he would play with her children and now
be nice with her and share food with her
and groom her and and that's how you can
see how much influence he had right
what is
how i guess the question is how far can
we go in relating
the inner
life the inner mental life of a typical
chimpanzee or bonobo to that of a human
i mean do they have
hopes and dreams do they think about the
future do they get embarrassed do they
have emotions are these even questions
we can think to answer well emotions are
my previous book mama's last hug is all
about animal emotions
i i personally don't think that there
are emotions that we have that they
don't have
i think
emotions is definitely something we
share with with all of them
thinking about the future we we do
increasingly experiments on planning
nowadays
it's called time travel
uh do you can you think ahead or can you
think backwards like that's episodic
memory can you sing backwards to
specific events and so time travel is
increasingly studied and we have good
evidence for time travel
forward uh in in planning sense for for
primates and for birds for certain birds
like the corvettes and so
the planning studies
let me give you an example of planning
we we have a little video clip of a
female bonobo named lisala who
in the sanctuary who picked up a very
heavy rock and put it on her back
a 15 pound rock and she started walking
with it
as he walked for a kilometer so she
walked like 15 minutes with the rock
and then she came to a place where she
found some nuts
and i think she knew where the nuts were
she picked up these nuts and she
continued her walk and then she went to
a place where there was a
hard surface
and she put down the nuts there and she
started cracking them with the big rock
that she had brought now if you think
about this that means that she picked up
her tool
15 minutes before she knew she would be
having the nuts there at that particular
location
and before she was even at at the place
where she could use the rock to crack
the nuts and so that kind of planning
uh in this case it was a spontaneous
case but we do increasingly experiments
on this kind of planning is present in
the apes which means they they can think
forward they can plan ahead i'm not sure
that they're dreaming about the future
if that's what you know that's not
something we can determine really but if
you can think ahead you can also dream
ahead i suppose
i guess if i want to sort of be a little
bit skeptical which maybe i don't want
to be but if i did uh is it possible to
invent some story where everything is a
moment by moment thought but you still
get the same answer i mean she had a
past experience of having a big rock and
that was useful for nuts and it was just
like she thought oh i should i should
bring my big rock with me when i go
walking around i mean how do we
disentangle these ideas scientifically
yeah that's of course
the strategy of the behaviorists the the
traditional
skin area and behaviorist their strategy
is to try to explain it on the basis of
associative learning and conditioning
and they have tried that for the last 25
years with the with the rise of
cognitive
studies on animals they have tried to
counter every example
with these conditioning explanations
but they have become less and less
successful with that because then of
course experiments are designed to show
that it is not conditioning that that's
what
the cognitive studies usually do
they have become less and less
successful and also their whole field
now consists mostly of countering ideas
instead of generating new ideas is that
they okay they're in the business of
shooting down explanations that the
cognitive scientists come up with and uh
it's it's becoming very tiresome
and
and it has helped us design better
studies
uh but i would say um it's largely
unsuccessful they're not taken so
seriously anymore we used to fight with
them and and then redesign the
experiments to make sure that we were
taking care of this conditioning
explanation
but i think um
we're now sort of tired of it and and
also the generation who does that is the
older generation the younger people
don't really care much about that
anymore i guess this brings up the
question can we
look into the brains of the primates to
see different things happening in
different parts of the brain and then
compare them with humans or is that
something that's just too hard to do
well we are in a situation where people
are training dogs and monkeys to be in a
brain scanner
okay so there is there is a non-invasive
neuroscience coming up for animals
and that may sometimes solve some of
these issues uh
it's it's really only in the beginning
stages
but um
i would prefer that we do it this way
than than the invasive neuroscience that
we've had in the past
you know where people remove a part of
the brain to see how the monkey behaves
after that
i always compare that with removing a
part of the engine of my car and see how
it still drives after that which i think
is not going to tell me very much but
people have done these things
i think we need to move to a
non-invasive neuroscience like
neuroimaging on animals and that's going
to happen uh if these apparatus get
smaller and if we can train the animals
like they're doing it with dogs and
monkeys if we can train them to be in
the scanner and sit still for a couple
of minutes and that's the way to go
and good so i think that this is a good
time to sort of wrap up by go getting
back to gender and and sexuality uh i
mean we started by talking about that
and you filled in a lot about
both the biology and the culture of uh
these primates
how
much of what we think of as human
the the great spectrum of human
sexuality so not only is there you know
heterosexuality homosexuality
transgender and cisgender but there's
also asexuality some people are just
more sexual than others etc do we see
all this kind of diversity in the
primate kingdoms or the primate species
well i think
we haven't been looking for it so
once you start looking for these things
you're gonna find it
so recently a study came out i think on
chimpanzees in the field where there was
more homosexual behavior than we have
ever realized and so and so this was
rarely reported in addition also because
people are a bit shy about sex
a lot of scientists like to talk a lot
more about violence than about sex
and that's also why the bonobo is often
overlooked because it makes many
scientists uncomfortable to talk about
their sexual activities
but once we start looking for it i think
we will find quite a bit of diversity in
in their behavior their sexual behavior
or sexual orientation maybe their sexual
identity even though
i wouldn't use the word identity because
we cannot really determine that but
let's say their typical sex role
behavior um
so i think there's much more diversity
than people think
uh is there an alteration through the
lifespan of an individual do they you
know go from being more masculine to
more feminine or or back or is it
something that more or less they figure
it out and they stick with it their
whole life
well there is a difference of course in
the sense that males
the testosterone levels of males
lower but this age as they do in humans
and so older males are usually
friendlier and easier going
than younger males
so for example in a in a gym society the
males
between 20 and 30 they are the ones who
are competing for the high status and
they are very active and they are
sometimes quite aggressive
the older males who are over 40
they take it easy and there's now data
on how they have friendships that are
more intimate with each other
because they're less focused
on
political alliances and more focused on
hanging out together and do things for
fun like human males who are older uh
they're more into that kind of stuff for
example older males i always find that
so fascinating is that i've known many
high-ranking chimpanzee males who once
they retired so to speak once they got
kicked out of their positions
still hung around in the group and and
became very popular grooming partners
for everyone but what they also do is
they play a lot more with kids
they they uh tickle and play and chase
with them and they have the greatest fun
something that as younger males they
never did because they they were much
too preoccupied with other things in
their life
and so yeah i think there is a very
interesting arc
in in the lifespan of of chimpanzees and
for females
they don't have menopause so you know
menopause is one of these things that
humans have and and we think that their
theories about it that we have menopause
because
of of grandmothers having an important
function supporting their daughters with
their kids
uh and so um females keep reproducing
till very old age
and and often uh we humans watching
chimpanzees and bonobos we sort of feel
for them because we then see a female
who's actually at an age that we think
she should also retire
and and have it easy uh we see her still
carrying a a big youngster on her back
and and so we we sort of feel for them
and we i think menopause was a great
advance for our society
that's a that is a great uh lesson to
take home here i mean maybe i'll i'll
ask you one last question and you can be
as expansive or or quick as you want um
for those of us who are human beings and
we're reading you know your books and
your stories about the the very wide
spectrum of behavior uh in all these
primates i mean what should our attitude
be or should we should it be to sort of
be inspired or to be to get cautionary
tales should we be
wary of over interpreting things in
human terms or should we just let our
imaginations do that well we should be
wary of
setting ourselves completely apart from
the animal kingdom as some people do you
know like we are humans they are animals
that's certainly an attitude that i
don't support
we should be wary also of saying that
everything we do is cultural and
everything animals do is instinctive
i think that's a total simplification
because a lot of the things that animals
do is cultural and a lot of things that
we do is biological
and so um
all these simplifications they um
they reduce actually our understanding i
think of ourselves so we don't always
fully understand ourselves because we we
make up stories about ourselves and uh i
see that you know i'm a biologist
who has worked
as 25 for 25 years as a in a psychology
department as a psychology professor
i've i've seen how psychology
is very much obsessed with the stories
that they tell themselves for example
they tell themselves that that
humans are not very hierarchical
that humans
especially women they have no
hierarchies men may have hierarchies but
women don't
you know we tell stories about ourselves
which i think are nonsense but we do
that um
and and then we start believing in them
and i think in that sense it's it's
important to look in the mirror and and
the primates provide a mirror then we
look at that mirror and and we get a
little bit better understanding of
ourselves
a reality check if nothing else yeah
yeah yeah
all right that's that's very good to
keep in mind so fronts to wall thanks so
much for being the winescape podcast
you're welcome i loved it yeah
[Music]
you